Puede que se estén preguntando por qué una bióloga marina de Oceana
viene hoy aquí a hablarles del hambre en el mundo.
Estoy hoy aquí porque salvar los océanos es más
que un deseo ecológico.
Lo hacemos por algo más que que por crear trabajos para los pescadores
o por preservarlos.
Es más que un objetivo económico.
Salvar los mares puede alimentar el mundo.
Déjenme mostrarles cómo.
Como saben, ya hay más de mil millones de personas que
pasan hambre en el planeta.
Se espera que este problema empeore por el aumento de la población mundial
a 9 o 10 mil millones para mediados de siglo,
y por tanto habrá más presión sobre nuestros recursos alimentarios.
Y esto es muy preocupante, sobre todo si consideramos
dónde estamos ahora.
Ahora sabemos que nuestro terreno cultivable per capita
está disminuyendo tanto en países desarrollados, como en vía de desarrollo.
Sabemos que nos precipitamos hacia un cambio climático
que va a modificar los patrones de lluvia, volviendo unas zonas más secas,
como se puede ver en naranja, y otras, más húmedas, en azul,
causando sequías en las cestas del pan, de lugares como el Medio Oeste
y Europa Central, e inundaciones en otros.
Será más difícil para la tierra firme ayudarnos a solucionar
el problema del hambre.
Por esto es necesaria la abundancia en el mar,
para que nos puedan proporcionar tanta comida como sea posible.
Y esto es lo que los océanos han estado haciendo por nosotros
durante mucho tiempo.
Volviendo la vista atrás, observamos un aumento
en la cantidad de alimentos que hemos podido extraer
de nuestros mares.
Parecía que iba a seguir aumentando hasta 1980,
cuando se empezó a ver un descenso.
Han oído hablar de la cima del petróleo.
Puede que esta sea la cima del pescado.
Espero que no. Volveré a ello más adelante.
Lo que sí se puede observar es un 18% de descenso
en la cantidad de pescado obtenida en la captura mundial desde 1980.
Y este es un gran problema. Sigue creciendo.
Esta línea roja sigue hacia abajo.
Pero sabemos cómo darle la vuelta, y esto es de lo que voy a hablar hoy.
Sabemos cómo hacer que la línea vaya en ascenso.
Esto no tiene por qué ser la cima del pescado.
Haciendo cosas simples en lugares específicos
podemos recuperar nuestras pesquerías y usarlas
para alimentar a la gente.
Primero queremos saber dónde está el pescado,
así que echemos un vistazo.
Resulta que el pescado, convenientemente, está situado en su mayoría
en áreas aledañas a los países, en zonas costeras,
áreas sobre las cuales las jurisdicciones nacionales
tienen control y manejan sus pesquerías en estas zonas costeras.
Los países costeros tienen jurisdicciones que comprenden
alrededor de 370 km desde la costa en áreas llamadas
zonas económicas exclusivas. Es bueno que se puedan controlar
sus pesquerías en estas zonas, porque en alta mar,
que son las zonas más oscuras del mapa, es mucho más difícil,
porque tendría que hacerse a nivel internacional.
Se mete uno en ámbitos internacionales y, si alguno de Uds. está siguiendo
el acuerdo del cambio climático, sabe que puede ser un proceso muy lento,
frustrante y tedioso.
Así que controlar las cosas a nivel nacional está muy bien.
¿Cuánto pescado hay en estas zonas costeras
comparado con alta mar?
Bueno, aquí se puede ver, alrededor de siete veces más pescado
en las zonas costeras que en alta mar, o sea que es un lugar perfecto
para centrarnos porque podemos hacer muchas cosas.
Podemos restaurar muchas de nuestras pesquerías
si nos centramos en las zonas costeras.
¿Pero en cuántos de estos países tenemos que trabajar?
Hay unos 80 países costeros.
¿Tenemos que arreglar la gestión de las pesquerías
en todos esos países?
Entonces, nos preguntamos, ¿en cuántos países debemos centrarnos,
sabiendo que la Unión Europea maneja convenientemente sus pesquerías
mediante una política pesquera común?
Y, si tenemos una buena gestión pesquera en la UE y, digamos, otros 9 países,
¿cuántas pesquerías tendríamos cubiertas?
Resulta que la UE más 9 países cubren unas dos terceras partes
de la captura de pescado mundial.
Si tomáramos 24 países, más la UE, subiría hasta el 90%,
casi toda la captura de pescado mundial.
Así que creemos que podemos trabajar en lugares concretos
para recuperar el sector de la pesca.
Pero ¿qué tenemos que hacer en estos lugares?
Bien, basándonos en nuestro trabajo en Estados Unidos
y otros sitios, sabemos que hay 3 cosas clave que tenemos que realizar
para recuperar el sector pesquero y son: establecer cuotas o límites
en la cantidad de pescado que se captura; reducir la captura incidental,
cuando se sacan y se matan peces que no eran nuestro objetivo
y que conlleva una gran pérdida; y, 3, proteger los hábitats,
las zonas de cría y de reproducción que los peces necesitan
para crecer y reproducirse y poder así repoblarse.
Si hacemos estas 3 cosas, recuperaremos el sector.
¿Cómo lo sabemos?
Lo sabemos porque lo hemos visto en muchos otros lugares.
Esta diapositiva muestra la población de arenques en Noruega
que decreció desde los años 50.
Fue disminuyendo y, cuando Noruega puso límites,
o cuotas, en el sector, ¿qué ocurrió?
La pesca volvió.
Este es otro ejemplo, también en Noruega, del bacalao polar.
Pasa lo mismo. La pesca está disminuyendo.
Ponen límites en los descartes.
Los descartes son los peces que no son el objetivo
y se tiran al mar, como desperdicio.
Al establecer límite al descarte, la pesca vuelve.
Y no solo en Noruega.
Hemos visto esto en otros países del mundo, una y otra vez.
Cuando estos países deciden instaurar políticas de gestión
de pesca sostenible, la pesca, que parece que siempre está disminuyendo,
empieza a volver.
Parece muy promisorio.
¿Qué significa esto para la captura de pescado mundial?
Significa que si tomamos esta captura pesquera
que está disminuyendo y podemos hacer que ascienda,
podríamos aumentarla en 100 millones de toneladas métricas por año.
No hemos llegado a la cima del pescado aún.
Todavía tenemos una oportunidad no solo para recuperar la pesca
sino para conseguir más pesca que pueda alimentar a más gente
de la que se puede beneficiar ahora.
¿Cuánta gente más? Justo ahora, podemos alimentar
cerca de 450 millones de personas con un plato de pescado al día
basándonos en la actual captura de pescado mundial,
que, por supuesto, está bajando. Es decir, ese número disminuirá
si no lo arreglamos. Pero si instauramos prácticas de gestión pesquera
como las que he descrito en 10 a 25 países, podríamos incrementar el número
y alimentar a 700 millones de personas en un año
con un sano plato de pescado.
Obviamente deberíamos hacer esto porque es bueno para tratar
el problema del hambre, pero también es rentable.
Resulta que el pescado es la proteína más rentable del planeta.
Si se fijan en cuánta proteína se obtiene por cada dólar invertido
comparado con otros animales,
obviamente, el pescado es una buena decisión empresarial.
Tampoco se necesita mucha tierra, que es escasa,
comparado con otras fuentes de proteínas.
Y no se necesita mucha agua dulce.
Utiliza mucha menos agua dulce que, por ejemplo, la ganadería,
donde se tiene que regar el campo para poder cultivar comida
para que el ganado paste.
También tiene un bajo impacto de carbono.
Conlleva un pequeño impacto de carbono porque tenemos que salir
para capturar el pescado.
Se necesita un poco de combustible, pero, como Uds. saben, la agricultura
tiene un impacto de carbono y el del pescado es mucho más pequeño.
Así que es menos contaminante.
Ya es una parte importante de nuestra dieta,
pero puede serlo aún más, y es algo bueno porque sabemos
que es saludable para nosotros.
Puede reducir el riesgo de cáncer, enfermedades cardíacas y obesidad.
De hecho, a nuestro Director Ejecutivo, Andy Sharpless,
el creador de esta iniciativa, le gusta pensar que el pescado
es la proteína perfecta.
Andy también señala el hecho de que nuestro movimiento
de conservación de los océanos viene del de conservación de las tierras.
Y en las conservación de tierras tenemos el problema
de que la biodiversidad está en guerra con la producción alimentaria.
Hay que reducir la biodiversidad de los bosques
si quieres campo para cultivar maíz para alimentar a la gente.
Hay un constante tira y afloja en este asunto.
Es duro tener que elegir
entre dos cosas muy importantes: mantener la biodiversidad
y alimentar a la gente.
Pero en el mar no hay esta guerra.
En el mar la biodiversidad no está en guerra con la abundancia.
De hecho, son aliadas.
Cuando trabajamos para producir biodiversidad,
obtenemos más abundancia. Esto es importante para poder
alimentar a la gente.
Ahora bien, hay una trampa.
¿Nadie se la ha pillado? (Risas)
La pesca ilegal.
La pesca ilegal debilita el tipo de gestión sostenible de pesca de la que hablo.
Puede ser cuando se captura pescado con técnicas
prohibidas, cuando se pesca en lugares
restringidos, cuando se captura el pescado
del tamaño o especie inadecuados.
La pesca ilegal engaña al consumidor y también a los pescadores honestos,
y se tiene que acabar.
El pescado ilegal llega a nuestro mercado a través de la pesca fraudulenta.
Puede que hayan oído hablar de esto.
Es cuando el pescado se etiquetea como lo que no es.
Piensen en la última vez que comieron pescado.
¿Qué comieron?
¿Están seguros de que era eso?
Porque nosotros examinamos 1300 muestras distintas de pescado
y cerca de un tercio de ellas no eran lo que las etiquetas decían.
9 de cada 10 pargos no lo eran.
El 59% de atún que examinamos estaba mal etiquetado.
Y el pargo rojo. Examinamos 120 muestras
y solo 7 de ellas eran realmente pargo rojo.
Así que, buena suerte cuando busquen pargo rojo.
El pescado tiene una cadena de suministro compleja,
y en cada paso de esta cadena
hay una oportunidad para el fraude, a menos que se le haga seguimiento.
El seguimiento es una forma como la industria pesquera
puede rastrear el pescado desde el bote hasta el plato
y asegurarse de que el consumidor pueda saber
de dónde viene su pescado.
Esto es muy importante.
Ya se está realizando en la industria, pero no lo suficiente.
Así que estamos llevando al Congreso la ley SAFE,
la Ley de la Comida de Mar. Me emociona anunciar el lanzamiento
de una solicitud de los chefs, por la que 450 chefs
han firmado una petición haciendo un llamamiento al Congreso
para apoyar SAFE, Ley de Comida de Mar.
La apoyan muchos chefs famosos que puede que conozcan—
Anthony Bourdain, Mario Batali, Barton Seaver, entre otros—
y la han firmado porque consideran que la gente tiene derecho a saber
lo que comen.
(Aplausos)
A los pescadores también les gusta. Así que hay una buena posibilidad
de que consigamos el apoyo necesario para aprobarla.
Llega en un momento crítico, porque esta es la forma de acabar
con el fruade en la pesca. Es la forma en que frenamos la pesca ilegal.
Es la forma como nos aseguramos que las cuotas, la protección del hábitat
y la reducción de la captura incidental puedan hacerse efectivas.
Sabemos que podemos gestionar nuestra pesca de forma sostenible.
Sabemos que podemos producir comida sana para centenares de millones de personas,
que no necesita de la tierra ni de mucha agua,
tiene bajo impacto de carbono y es rentable.
Sabemos que salvar los océanos puede alimentar el mundo.
Pero necesitamos empezar ahora.
(Aplausos)
Gracias. (Aplausos)